there's a video going around viral of
some cop
you know australia's under very serious
covid lockdowns a cop shows up wearing
one of these dinky little masks and she
she walks up to a person's private
residence
and she begins to explain why it's very
very wrong and awful and illegal that
this person
even suggested that maybe
they might go out and protest the
lockdowns
is there a reason why you're recording
me today yes for my protection
do you think i'm going to assault you or
something no um
so
i don't understand why you're here
and i haven't even spoken to you and you
think i'm going to
do something to you well we have seen a
lot of police violence in recent times
towards the public and there is a
growing
there's a growing mistrust i as you can
understand um
yeah not here do anything like that all
right let's go we're here to have a chat
to you because we have instructions that
um you've been posting some things on
social media
and
that you
it's about a protest protest on
tuesday um there's no protest on tuesday
there isn't okay that's fine but what
i'm here is to remind you to ensure that
you need to stay at home in relation to
covert
and
stay-at-home orders and if there is or
is not a protest on tuesday regardless
you still can't leave and go to a
protest of any sort i understand monday
tuesday wednesday thursday anything like
that
you i just want to to talk to you about
something yeah yeah i don't know what
accent i'm doing yeah yeah i just want
to talk to you about something yeah it's
like a mixture of east london and south
african yeah yeah well what you i saw
what you posted on there on the twitter
and you said you might protest the
government
no no you cannot do that i was spying on
your social media and i saw you
protested the government and you cannot
do this wrong and you see how how
concerned this cop is no look it's just
for you yeah you just you can't do that
yeah
you know how much i love my pillow one
because it's a patriotic company we all
like that but two even if they were run
by chinese communists i'd still buy from
them
that is because their their product is
just so good it's the best one out there
well my pillow wants to give back to our
listeners you can get great discounts on
all of my pillow products if you go to
mypillow.com right now click on the
radio listeners specials
get deep discounts on my pillow mattress
toppers towels so much more for example
my pillow is offering a buy one get one
free offer on the giza sheets they are
top quality sheets you are going to love
them all my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty it could be a 50-year
warranty you're not going to want to
return them they're that good
you're not going to want to
send them back you're you might want to
buy multiple sets like i have done
they're just a top quality product go to
mypillow.com click on the radio listener
specials for the buy one get one free
offer on the giza sheets use promo code
daily wire at checkout or call 800 651
1148 you'll also get deep discounts on
all those other my pillow products the
pillow the towel sets the
slippers the mattress topper that's
mypillow.com enter daily wire or call
800-651-1148 tell them dailywire sent
you
800-651-1148 the deals won't last
forever so call now all right when i cut
it out with this accent i sound like
some just east london soccer hooligan
this sort of thing is it is coming here
already it already kind of is here in
the united states so it's not as quite
as widespread as it is in australia
what's most interesting about this club
to me
is that you've got an ostensibly
conservative woman
using some of the same rhetoric here
about cops as you might hear from blm
there have been a lot of incidents with
the cops the cops are encroaching on our
rights there have been some violent
incidents like when the cops start
spraying you with rubber bullets and so
i'm filming you for my protection
you hear that same thing about from blm
here in the united states that the cops
are out you know racists and they're all
going to just try to hunt down this
innocent black guys
now i point this out because the in the
institutions in the west broadly are
crumbling
people don't have faith in them anymore
hugh hewitt said that at the top i don't
have faith in the cdc i don't have faith
in the fda when neither side has faith
in our elections in 2016 all the dems
said that hillary actually won in 2020
all the republicans said that trump
actually won
blm says that the cops are not to be
trusted and are overstepping their
bounds the conservatives now are saying
the very same thing now
so this poses a big problem for the
establishment but i i want to be careful
here i'm not saying that both sides are
making equally valid claims
when blm says that there's an epidemic
of cops going out racist cops trying to
kill innocent black people it's just not
true it just isn't happening it's not
backed up by any evidence or any
statistics whatsoever actually very very
very very few
black men innocent black men are killed
by the cops every year infinitesimally
few and even unarmed black men which
doesn't mean unjust shootings are very
very low numbers okay so
that those claims are false whereas
the claims that cops are shutting down
businesses that claims the cops are
people keeping people locked in the
claims the cops are showing up to
churches and shutting them down that is
happening and that did happen for a lot
of 2020 and it's still happening and
it's happening notably in australia okay
so those are different things
the claims that trump cheated in 2016
because he colluded with the russians or
whatever there was a multi-million
dollar investigation of this it just
wasn't true it's completely false
okay the claims that there were
shenanigans in the 2020 election are
obviously true forget even for a second
the audits which have raised i've talked
about it on the show have raised some
serious concerns about the integrity of
the election but even just the the way
that all the election integrity measures
were taken away
so many of them before before 2020 that
in
pennsylvania the way the the election
was conducted was in violation of the
state constitution
the the use of ubiquitous unsolicited
widespread mail-in ballots the use of
ballot drop boxes
all of these raise questions and so i
don't i'm not saying well both sides are
making these claims saying one side is
making much more serious and justifiable
claims than the other one but neither
side has
trust in the institutions anymore which
is really bad news
for
the ruling class i'm glad you liked that
clip get the whole show either here at
the michael knowles show on youtube or
at apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your
podcasts type it in the michael knowles
show subscribe
click that button we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you